[Music]
hello and welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv a movie channel
i am here at the moment to do a very
impromptu last minute live video because
i made a mistake
wait a minute you're actually saying
that you need someone dumber than you
are
you may have come to the right place i
basically said
that brad wright um is in
hollywood he's actually in
los angeles at the mgm headquarters
having meetings on tuesday
in the video i also said that the source
that i speak to at mgm had seen brad
right in the building on monday
brad wright then messaged me
which is a bit like being told off by
your dad whose idea was this
did you think this was a good idea
who got the paint out
the creator of my favorite tv show ever
to tell me that he's not in la and this
isn't true initially i thought that that
message on youtube was probably fake i
get a lot of fakeness she's got a lot of
[ __ ] message stuff people trying to
wind me up so i thought it's probably
not true i then checked his twitter feed
and no it was true um he isn't in la or
he says he's internally
and he's not attending these meetings
so i immediately messaged my source with
a
what the f in hell is going on why have
you told me this um i do get a lot of
information from people that i can't
verify and i don't share it because i
can't verify it in this case i do know
that the chat in question does work for
mgm is from california i've checked as
much as possible that he is who he says
he is the other possibility is that brad
wright was actually being dishonest but
that is really unlikely that he actually
is at these meetings isn't supposed to
tell anyone i've let the cat out of the
bag do my video
so
he has tried to nip it in the bud i
think that is incredibly unlikely for
one he's canadian i don't think they are
capable of lying but also he wouldn't go
out of his way
to actually like go yeah no this isn't
true
um if if if it was so i really don't
think that's true
um another thing was they said maybe he
isn't in la but maybe he's going to join
these meetings by zoom somebody asked
him out on twitter and he said no that's
also not the case
so i really locked down on my source to
ask him what the hell is going on
first of all
on the brad right actually seeing brad
wright so it says are you certain it was
him and he went i i was i was certain it
was him
um but he was wearing a mask
and i'm like what
the meetings that were penciled in are
you certain his name was on these
meetings to to attend these meetings and
he's adamant he was do you remember
these sources that i speak to mgm they
talk to me because
um i listen
but also they told me because they're
massive fans of stargate they love
stargate as much as we do so they want
this information to get out they want
their opinions to connect
um these are rumors that go around any
office building again these people that
i've talked to they're not high up
executives or anything they're they're
normal in some cases normal people that
work in and around the building
so
rumors go around the building as well i
try to tell you when these things are
rumors
i didn't actually believe him when he
told me he'd seen brad right so i tried
to sort of when i did this video that
i've now deleted by the way and because
i don't if it's not true i don't want it
on the channel
um
but
you know i i said to him
i wasn't really sure um so i said this
is what he said he said he saw it from
across the room he has spoken to brad
right before so he was nine percent
certain of i wasn't sure i will share
them with you because the rumors that
come from the mgm building they come
from the mgm company so i think they're
worth sharing this it's worth the risk
to share them
in this case it's bit me in the ass
but it's not all bad news
because when brad wright did message me
he also said that he's sure these
meetings are actually happening
he's just not been invited to them
but for example when joseph melosi
tweeted that he'd seen the script um and
he had his light reading over the
weekend the sin the script that brad
writes produced
um a script that brad wright says he
actually wrote nearly a year ago and i
was told was edited and um was only
actually seen by amazon people about a
month or six weeks ago but
um broderick says he wrote it a year ago
um
i had that information on my channel
within 24 hours
gateworld and other channels like
podcasting on this took nearly a week
made a mistake i apologize to brad
wright because i wasted his time i've
wasted other people's time and i hate
that yes rodney i shot you and i said i
was sorry
you shot me too i'm sorry for shooting
everyone
but
silver lining brad white did confirm
that he is absolutely certain these
meetings are happening
um they're happening this week and
hopefully we'll start getting something
a bit more concrete to come out
about our favorite tv show really really
soon
but i think i know they've talked about
it you remember i did a video a few
months ago and i said that um
brad wright was in the building at um
beverly hills and i had to apologize to
say no he wasn't
um i've since been told
that actually um this was completely
separate i only told this about two
weeks ago that there were a bunch of
meetings about brad right
um at um executive things just before
these big summits and i never put two
and two together initially
uh but now i've suddenly realized i
wonder if that's what the bloke saw
he saw the brad's name his name when it
was about
he wasn't actually attending but he
wasn't actually tempted so it was um so
i i do one i've never i haven't actually
asked the bloke that told me because um
he stopped talking to me after that
after i did the video and i apologized
um he virtual hug thank you thank you
jack
um he i basically he thought that i was
calling him a liar
and because he said i am a hundred
percent convinced
i saw his name on these meetings and
then i come obviously that video saying
i'm sorry brad wright has told me
himself he wasn't there and i do think
this guy genuinely made a genuine
mistake he basically saw bradson
wright's name on these meetings
saw a bloke that he thought was brad
wearing a bloody mask across the room
and then just put two two together and
made six
so i think it was a genuine mistake but
now this other guy's told me now there
were a bunch of means about but it was
simply they weren't like anything
nefarious it was simply
the mgm executives and people know brad
the amazon people coming in don't know
him stargate is considered to be a big
role so they had some means to say well
you know what what's he like what are
his priorities what does he want to do
and that's all these meetings were
apparently but um
[Music]
that's what happened
i'm hoping so because but like i said
he's never he's never spoken to me since
you know says he thinks i thought called
him a liar and i wasn't i was trying to
be really honest but the other day if
brad wright
tells you off
and says i wasn't there
you know
you don't have a choice you've got to
issue an apology
[Music]
you